old radio in the 60s
more vintage turntables
I prefer repairing old stuff because I
can actually fix it like it comes in
it's fixed I got a happy customer inside
the door repair isn't John Fidel's blood
American Electronics is a family-owned
repair shop in Toronto's West End John's
father Frank vadel started the business
in 1973.
[Music]
back in the 70s and 80s companies used
to have parts counter deaths
I used to ride my bicycle to these uh
factories and pick up parts for my
father
a lot has changed since then Parts
counters have gone by the wayside and
technology has become more sophisticated
and more difficult to repair but not for
the reasons you think
there isn't any reason that the stuff we
have today is harder to fix than stuff
from 20 years ago it's really the system
that has atrophy manufacturers used to
sell parts over the last 20 30 years
they've systematically stopped doing
that hey I'm Kyle with iFixit and we're
going to take some stuff apart today
iFixit was Kyle ween's radical response
it's a website that offers everything
most manufacturers won't repair guides
tools and parts more and more these days
we get products from manufacturers and
they don't have a plan for us to be able
to maintain it
that's herding repair shops and fueling
our throwaway culture and it has Grave
implications for the environment and our
wallets Kyle is part of a growing
movement of people pushing back right to
repair is the idea that if you bought it
you should be able to fix it
but even skilled technicians like John
have to go to Great Lengths to do simple
repairs once the product becomes out of
warranty we cannot call the
manufacturers directly we are referenced
to a third-party Logistics type
companies just basically warehousing
companies
those companies will sell John an
entirely new circuit board for a couple
hundred dollars
but often he just needs a tiny component
part I've gotten quotes for boards that
are more than three quarters the price
of the product it just it doesn't make
sense
even when he finds that tiny part it
only introduces a new headache the issue
becomes then shipping if I'm ordering
from China I'm waiting two months in
order for the little product to arrive
at the door and it's tiny by then he's
wasted a day and has an angry customer
on his hands who doesn't want to pay
that much or wait that long
so what do most people do buy a new one
the run around that they put us through
is absolutely crazy and unfortunately
the customer doesn't see that end of it
and there's the board that I need to
work on and the manufacturer is claiming
it's not serviceable
even still John is busier than ever
granted I'm still going strong but I'm
finding it harder and harder day after
day
repair is an integral part of the
economy and increasingly our small
repair shops are withering away we need
to get back to where service and repair
is a Cornerstone of our local economies
many products today are specifically
built not to last this planned
obsolescence is often called designed
for the dump for example batteries glued
into smartphones which makes them
difficult to replace or software updates
that are incompatible with older devices
we absolutely can make products that
last longer if we want to right now the
companies are making so much money
selling us a new thousand dollar phone
every two years that they don't really
have an incentive so we have a
misalignment between what Society needs
and what is what is profitable for some
of the largest corporations in the world
companies argue they are protecting
consumers safety and privacy by
restricting who's able to do repairs and
also that by withholding repair
information and parts they are
safeguarding their Intel actual property
rights
all these old devices add up
the electronic recycling association's
Warehouse in Toronto is always full this
fullness happens every day we can't get
rid of it
manager oledayo adebayo sends out trucks
across Southern Ontario to collect
unwanted Electronics do clients tell you
why they're getting rid of this stuff
most of the time it's just because they
don't sizing or they trying to bring
newer models
truck driver Henry and his assistant
David
E-Waste is the world's fastest growing
waste stream
in 2019 alone a record 54 million tons
of electronic waste was thrown out
yeah what's next
it's been computers two laptops five
monitors and a few printers
most of this stuff still works newer
models will be sent to the non-profits
Calgary headquarters to be repaired and
then donated the rest gets recycled
but the recycling industry cannot keep
Pace with the world's appetite for
electronics
and making all this new tech is what
causes the most pollution waste and
environmental harm
we are literally digging a mountain out
of the Earth every day to make and feed
the beast that is our regular electronic
consumption and as more new things run
on software repair shops and DIY types
face a new barrier digital locks that's
when you can't do a fix without special
software and manufacturers often keep
those tools to themselves and and the
moment that you have copyright control
over all of our physical objects that
passes control from the owner from you
to the manufacturer and they get to
dictate what happens at every step of
the way the right to repair is about
giving people more control over the
things they already own with the
movement gaining momentum big tech
companies have begun to make some
concessions Apple has launched a DIY
repair program Google and Samsung now
sell parts for their phones Nokia and
Microsoft are making more repairable
products but Advocates say in order to
fix all our devices we need to repair
the entire system we have to pass laws
to construct the kind of society we want
to live in and at the moment we're very
biased in favor of Manufacturers and
against local repair options it's a
fundamental human right to have access
to the knowledge to how to fix all the
things that we depend on for Modern Life